you seem to overlook the fact that some
infant children were raised in
undisciplined environments with
undisciplined parents I hate the fact
that I have gross undisciplined
behaviors you don't get discipline from
your parents you don't inherit it and
there's another piece here it's called
ownership right it's called ownership
and if you're if you want to blame other
people for the problem and I say this
all the time if you don't take ownership
of the problem the problem's not going
to get solved so if you blame your
parents for not having raised you in a
disciplined environment you're not going
to solve that problem